measures for the invitation it's my
pleasure to present our recent line
research about developing this Simulator
for single cell and spatial omics data
so our purpose includes benchmarking and
data and model inference from data and
also to generate in Silicon controlled
experiments
so first of all let me briefly introduce
the structure a common structure of
single cell spatialomics data from a
statistical modeling perspective the
process data would be a sale by feature
Matrix and by sale I mean broadly it
could be a spot in spatialomics which
may be considered multiple cells jointly
but here I would just refer to it by
itself and also a covariate matrix where
the rows are cells but we have multiple
covariates to describe every cell I will
give some examples so the cells may have
some heterogeneity structure that are
observed or not so the structure could
be discrete cell types or a continuous
trajectory of cells or their spatial
locations so this is known for
spatialomics data and for the
experimental design that were used to
generate the data they may include
batches which are the effects we don't
want or conditions which are the
biological signals we want
and finally we have multiple features
nowadays the most common one is gene
expression we have this for single cell
artistic data or spatial transcriptomics
data or we can have the chromata
accessibility in single cell a toxic
data and snare seek is a technology that
can give us both signature expression
and chromatic accessibility and we can
we may also even have protein abundance
data so a rich data resource and the
motivation for our development is first
benchmarking computational tools so as
we know this is a very popular field and
this website has a collection of the
computational tools for single cell
rnaistic data there are already more
than 1 000 tools up to date and so from
a user's perspective how can we choose
the most appropriate tool for our
analysis that's the question and the
second question is can we do inference
on this data so here are some typical
questions I'm listing so conditional
cell covariate for example this sales
type or the sales studio time in the
trajectory or the sales spatial location
can we infer every Gene's distribution
and can we infer Gene pair's correlation
and the gene can be replaced by other
features
and finally how can we design in Silicon
controlled experiments so this is
motivated by real biology experiments we
have to use negative control and
sometimes we need to add positive
control so we can evaluate the results
however this is often lacking in
computational pipelines so we hope to
offer a way to generate the controls to
evaluate the results
so for all the purposes we need a
realistic simulator with interpretal
parameters
so we started this journey in 2019 with
this work SC design so that one was
designed for you know user simulator to
help optimize the trade-off between the
number of sales and the sequencing depth
from the perspective of detecting
differential Express genes between two
cell types so the pros of this method
includes that it's a probabilistic model
with interpretable parameters and we
model sales as observations so therefore
the cell number is the sample size we
can vary the sample size and we can vary
the total sequencing depth as the budget
so we can find the trade-off
and my former student used this method
for benchmarking the doublet detection
methods the computational approaches
which double detection is a necessary
step in single cell rnsic data
processing and we have some interesting
results
however we also realized this acid
design has counts the biggest count is
that it models genes as independent
variables then that's okay from the
perspective of differential expression
because we look at genes one by one but
for other analysis this is not okay
because the cells are not that realistic
and also in acid design we will first do
a log transformation of the count and
then use normal distribution and that's
considered not as straightforward as
modeling accounts directory
okay so motivated by those limitations
we take a look at the existing
simulators in the field so I try to
summarize them from different aspects
and I want to highlight this Gene
correlation capture we can see that most
methods couldn't do the job and also
most methods couldn't vary the cell
number sample size or the sequencing
depth and many of them don't even
preserve genes so motivated by this we
have our version too as they design two
which is a different formulation so we
want to model count directly and also we
want to preserve Gene Gene correlations
using by modeling the genes joint
distributions so that the cells will be
more realistic and we also want to
preserve the advantages of acid design
for allowing variable number of cells
and varying sequencing depth for
experimental design
and there are two related work also
considers ging correlation that they
have some differences so this one from
caffeine rotors group they would allow
users to specify marginal distributions
of genes as input while we will infer
that from data and this other method
doesn't allow varying sequencing depth
okay so I will first describe acid
design to technically briefly so we
would denote the gene Matrix count
Matrix as a p by n Matrix here the rows
are features pgs The Columns are the
observations and cells we would assume
that the cells are already divided into
K cell types and so we know which cell
belongs to which cell type so this is
considered as prior information in the
simulator and then we will focus on the
small case cell type and we look at the
sub Matrix with the corresponding cells
as the columns and the pigeons as the
rows so our goal is to fit a parametric
probabilistic model for all genes
expression in the cell type K so for the
Simplicity of notation I would drop the
K notation in the following discussion
and just focus on one cell type
so we want to model counts directly our
first step is to model the marginal
distribution of each gene I
so given Gene I and I go from 1 to P we
have this count Vector for cell J
so we consider each cell as a random
Vector so this is one cell P dimensional
vector
and we would use the small X to denote
The observed count of Gene ion subject
so our goal is to select a marginal
count distribution for Gene ice count
and we would allow a different count
distribution for different genes so we
consider four common count distributions
poisson negative binomial and their
corresponding zero inflated versions to
account for the sparsity in single cell
data
and for the joint distribution which is
the key part for our modeling the P by P
right how can we get the P dimensional
joint distribution so we will use the
copula framework in statistics to do the
job so the idea is that given we have
each Gene's marginal distribution for
Gene I I call this fi so for the pgs we
have F1 to FP and to link them or to
couple them into a p dimensional joint
distribution we need a scapular function
C
okay so with this then we can have the P
dimensional joint distribution of the
pgs but the key result for the copula
thing is that the P distributions F1 to
FP they must be continuous so there's a
unique copular function to Define The
p-dimensional Joint distribution however
in our case the P marginal distributions
are discrete so we try to address this
issue by using distribution of transform
which essentially converts each discrete
distribution into a continuous
distribution by uniformly distribute The
Point Mass between two consecutive
discrete values into their interval so
to obtain this continuous distribution
F1 to FP we apply this transformation
and then we use the gaussian copula to
couple the P marginal distributions into
a joint distribution and so in this
gaussian copula the only parameter we
need to estimate is this P by P
correlation Matrix so with this and then
with the F12 FP we estimate that for the
marginal distributions we obtain the
drawing distribution for the feedings
okay so then the estimation procedure
we've done this we've done this in two
steps the first is to estimate marginal
distribution for every Gene and then we
apply this on this the transformation
technique to make the distribution
continuous and then we use the transform
values to obtain the gaussian
correlation Matrix so essentially we
would apply the standard normal inverse
transformation CDF transformation to
every value here and then we use the
transform vectors to estimate the this
correlation Matrix as the sample
correlation Matrix
so I will skip the generation part so
essentially with the fitted joint model
and we can specify the cell type
proportions which can be estimated from
real data or specified by users and
nozzle users can specify the number of
synthetic cells they want and the total
sequencing depth which we will use to
adjust the model parameters
proportionally then we can obtain a
synthetic Gene by cell count Matrix with
the K cell types and also we can output
the fitted model parameters for
interpretation
so this is what we can see right this is
a data used for model fitting this is a
data reserve for validation this is the
synthetic data and we can see copula
plays a critical role without using that
the synthetic data would look like this
and not look like real data and these
are two competing methods which use
different formulation and we put them
here for comparison because they have
some implicit modeling for to account
for changing correlations but not as
explicit as our framework so we can see
that they are synthetic that are not
very similar that as similar as what we
have here
and we also this is a summary so
basically we have a multi-gen
probabilistic model for each cell type
and the key is to capture gingering
correlations using the calculator
framework
so this is the work we published last
year and
that's not yet so we can see that here
the limitation is that we are only
generating synthetic data for these
Crystal types however the cells may come
from a continuous trajectory right so
then we want to generalize this marginal
distribution of Gene I inclj to be
dependent on flexible cell Jase
covariance and they may include the cell
type which is what we have already or
the sales pseudo time in a trajectory or
spatial coordinates or the sales
conditions or batches we hope to
incorporate all of those into our
synthetic data generation
so to achieve that we generalize the
marginal distribution modeling to use
the generalized editing model so in this
model we can allow the negative binomial
distribution for Gene I so that mean
parameter can be a non-linear function
of cell covariance so then we can
incorporate covert into the generation
so this is our mod version three so we
call this essay design three which is a
week I call this Omnibus single cell
spatialomics simulator what they can
achieve is that the cells can follow
continuous trajectory in addition to
discrete cell types and the feature
modalities has been generalized from
rna-seq to more features like open
chromatin protein spatial coordinates
and also we can allow model selection by
likelihood so our simulator after 32
real data can output the likelihood then
we can use Criterion like Bic for model
selection so this is a quick snapshot
about what a new simulator can do so
this is the real data this is essay
design 2 which will divide sales into
clusters first and SC design 3 can fit a
continuous trajectory so more realists
they can assign tool for this data and
furthermore we can see that this is the
real data we can generate data with a
dividing bifurcating trajectory top is
One Direction and the bottom is another
Direction while in other simulators they
cannot really use the studio time as
ground truth in Generations so in other
words they do not provide a trajectory
for benchmarking and of course we can
also generate data for benchmarking data
modality integration so like here the
cells here have RNA seek only the cells
here have methylation only so if we want
to Benchmark a method that does this
cross-feature integration we can
generate cells that have both modalities
and then use the integration method to
do the integration and do the comparison
and this is what we can do for spatial
data
and finally my other student has
generated has developed a new
functionality so that we cannot just
generate counts but also the reads so
basically here is the dimensional
reduction of cells using counts this is
real sales synthetic cells and this is
the corresponding browser track for the
read so being able to generate reads
will allow us to Benchmark the tools
that does the low level processing not
just counts
so here's just a figure showing what
this new simulator can do for the
simulation part it can generate data
from different cell States and also
different features and also different
experimental designs
and for the application part we'll apply
the simulator to real data we can infer
the model parameters so to interpret our
data and we can also do model selection
based on the likelihood and also we can
do model alteration we can alter the
model in a way that matches our null
hypothesis so we can generate the
synthetic node data
so lastly I want to say why do I need in
silicone controlled experiments so this
is from the Can Academy website so we
know that in the real biological
experiment we need a negative control so
we can really evaluate our experimental
outcome
however in single cell inference
problems it's very tricky because we
have a pipeline that will analyze the
same data for more than once this is
called double dipping and so for example
one example is that we would often
cluster cells first and then identify
differential Express genes ddgs between
cell types
so why is this problematic we could
imagine that if there's no clusters at
all we force the cells to be divided by
expression data then we could still find
some differential Expressions between
the forced cell clusters and that may
not be the thing we want
so there are three existing papers that
discuss this topic the first two use the
so-called selective inference framework
to obtain some closed form solutions for
the statistical test that they have to
assume that the genes follow gaussian
distributions
and maybe just a week ago from also from
Daniella wooten's group she posted
another bio archive paper new archive
paper which doesn't require gaussian
distribution assumption anymore that
they will require to split every Gene
ice counting cell J randomly displaying
that can't exit into two counts so I
have to say we didn't do a specific
comparison with the approach yet but
from my perspective they'd use a
different formulation so in their
formulation the sales are not
observations but fixed so in other words
in their formulation the cell number is
fixed as n well we cannot change the
cell number and that's what's different
from our formulation
so our proposal is to use our simulator
to generate a corresponding synthetic
null and then use another approach I'll
describe very soon to achieve the FDR
control so the whole idea is inspired by
the Gap statistic for selecting number
of clusters and the knockoff procedure
for controlling the FDR Force Discovery
rate
so let's take a look at this data this
is the real data so if we want to know
whether there are two clusters or not
before we do the differential expression
analysis just doing a permutation of the
cell type labels is not sufficient
because you can see that here in the
middle permutation will disrupt the
labels but the cell's shapes will be
preserved while using our essay design 3
simulator we could actually generate
snow data that looks like real data but
there are no more cell clusters so this
will serve as a negative control for
testing whether there are two clusters
or not
so the Clipper is motivated by The
Knockout procedure and so the goal is to
achieve your control without requiring
high resolution p-values because this is
usually served as the intermediate for
FDR control right and also to achieve
high resolution p-values we would often
require either parametric assumptions or
large sample sizes to achieve the
p-values and if we require large sample
sizes to do permutation like tests then
the p-value calculation can be
computational intensive so we want to
avoid those Troubles by using this
p-value free after control so the goal
is to do multiple testing with deep
features and we are the difference
between what we do here in The Knockout
paper is that we are doing marginal
feature screening instead of putting
them into a high dimensional prediction
model so in marginal feature screening
we examine one feature at a time so the
idea is to construct a contrast score
one per feature and pull in the contrast
score together the theoretical condition
for FDR control is that for the features
that are from the null their absolute
value of the contrast scores and the
contrast score signs would be
independent which explains which which
should mean that the majority of the
contrast scores should be symmetric
about zero and only a small proportional
features should have contrast scores in
the Sprite tail so this formula is
trying to find the threshold here the
dashed line here so that this ratio
which means the denominator is the
number of features on the right of the
stash line the numerator is the number
of features to the left of this
negativity of the stash line plus one so
you can consider this as an empirical
estimate of FDR but the theory can
guarantee that by setting this T to
satisfy that this ratio is less circular
heels we try to push the stash line to
the left as much as possible that is
where we can set a cutoff and then we
can control the FDR so we can see that
we save the trouble of calculating P
values that just need to construct the
contrast scores
so this is our Clipper paper published
last year
and applying here that to this context
the cluster de problem so we can we can
construct contrast score for future J or
Gene J using this simple formula so we
just need to have our real data as a
Target and the No data generated as the
negative control from Acid design three
and apply a pipeline the same pipeline T
to both data and then do the contrast
and the idea is that if this feature
just not interesting then this
difference will be equally likely
positive or negative regardless of its
absolute value
so this is a very preliminary result of
this idea so suppose that this is the
real data which don't which don't look
like a clusters right there's no
clusters and if we use your rad
clustering the popular pipeline or the
standard classical campaigns clustering
we can still divide the cells into two
clusters and visually we can see that
between the two clusters we will be able
to find some differential Express genes
this is exactly the double dipping
problem because the same expression data
were used for clustering so no wonder
the two clusters will be different in
terms of gene expression but if we use
our essay design 3 to generate no data
we can see that it serves as a very good
control and it is similar to real data
so we can imagine that no D genes should
be called from this comparison
and this is what we get so for this
example if we run the red Pipeline with
its building statistical tests many
tests they all have FDR equal to one
because they will always find the French
Expressions between the two clusters but
using our approach SC design 3 plus
Clipper we can control the FDR very well
so the take-home messages include that
we prefer the simulator S3 design 3 for
method benchmarking parameter inference
which I didn't talk about and also in
Silicon Control Data generation
and double dipping is a very common
problem in genomic data science because
we often need a complex pipeline for
data analysis and statistical inference
is the last step
and our proposal is to use sc93 for
generating data from a specified node
and use Clipper for controlling FDR
without requiring high resolution
p-values and this is still important
because it means that we only need to
generate no data for once so that can
save our computational time
so finally I want to thank my former
student Vivian for starting this line
research by developing as a design and
tie for essay design too and don't run
for the version 3 and also going out for
the read generating part and also shinjo
for the Clipper another question for the
current integration part and also the
funding agencies thank you
thanks a lot we have time for questions
yes
thanks Jessica very interesting so for
the um for capturing dependence between
genes have you considered Beyond a
gaussian caplas uh you know a couple of
models that can model asymmetries and so
on and yeah can you tell us a little bit
more about that yeah so far we haven't I
understand that there can be better
copulas that the reason is because we
found gaussian couple worked reasonably
well for the data generation the
synthetic that mimicroad very well so we
didn't actually further optimize that
part but I totally agree that this may
not be the optimal choice but the
interesting thing is that since our
primary goal is data generation right so
even though for the and that's the
automation that for the correlation
Matrix estimation part one is high
dimensional when no there will be some
issues right however we found that for
from the perspective perspective the
data generation it can work pretty well
for p of Tuesday 2000 yeah if we
selected two thousand heart Express
genes it can work pretty well well and
we didn't try to those more sparse
estimation method because of
computational efficiency yeah thank you
hi Jessica I think I might meet meets
some parts so I'm I got confused because
I think double dipping is a true problem
very serious issue but I think in your
essay design too you still need some
cell features or uh like the pseudo time
or the cell type but they're still
calculated yes yeah so how you avoid
and the thing is that we okay so I think
the key is here
so I think you're right so in our no
data generation we need to use those
features right but when we generate the
null data we will try to remove the
so-called variables over interest so for
example if the real data is classified
as or cluster that's two clusters and
what data Generations start from the two
clusters and the reason of that is we
want to mimic or estimate the G marginal
distribution and genjing correlation
which should be conditional on that
covariate and then when we generate the
node data we will remove the covariate
so that's the advantage of using this
probabilistic model because we can
decide which parameters to alter
ourselves and then when we generate the
null data you can see that even though
we use the date model fitted from real
data but this synthetic cells are
independent of the real data because we
are generating synthetic cells randomly
by sampling so therefore here the
comparison
is from the first step so there's double
dipping here there's double dipping here
as well we apply the same pipeline to
two parts so if you want to be more
rigorous I want to say that here we when
we say the condition when we say the now
data generation conditional real data we
are conditioning sorry I should say that
we are conditioning on the real data
because we are treating the parameters
for generally denoted as fixed in this
case
okay yeah yeah but but as you said so
there's not much we could do for not
using the target data still covariance
because otherwise the no data wouldn't
look like real data right I agree yeah
thanks
foreign
distribution could be a poisson or a
zero inflated negative binomial anything
in between so does it mean that your
copular model sort of uh it's a mix of
this distribution uniformly exactly okay
and the second question is like what is
the proportion That You observe of genes
in a typical data set that is like zero
inflated versus no they're very
interesting yeah and we have another
paper which I didn't put here for
showing that result so if the data are
using umis is Umi based single cell data
unique molecular identifier then I would
say 99 we can fit a gene distribution
while using pasta analytical binomial we
don't need a negative inflated component
but if it's smart C2 which don't use a
VMI then probably 50 we will use the
zero inflated component yeah so in our
answer design two paper although I only
show one figure here but we have many
results for different Technologies and
this is actually a smart stick too I
think
okay thank you
thank you this is actually I think a
question almost for both of you so so
putting together sort of your patterns
on the spatial distribution and putting
together your methods for doing the
simulations on a spatial yeah great I'm
curious just sort of your sense of how
much of the evidence that's out there is
experimental error
um how much is really sort of
um traveling by say inheritance of cell
type and how much is real different in
the distributions of either expression
or really the sort of isoform question
I'm curious you must have some way of
doing if not isoform directly sort of
pseudo-isoform and the degree to which
that's relevant so I'm just a sort of
thought discussion yeah I think that's a
very nice question and that's aligned
with my proposal here for the negative
content positive control right so for
example example in spatial data we can
fit this model for every slice and let's
say we're doing a comparison between two
slices what we could do for positive
control is that we could just generate
data without batch effects in our model
so we can know oh these genes have no
changes for sure and these changes have
these chains have changes with no
compounding factors from the batches and
we can also have the negative control to
include batch effects because we could
add battery fats in the gene specific
way or Universal to our genes and then
we can run the pipeline to see how
robust the results are so these are the
things we could do like in physical
experiments with our simulator yeah yeah
so
do you have a sense of you know how much
should you trust today the results that
are coming out on spatial heterogeneity
it's kind of like early on right single
cell data is like yeah it's noisy and we
don't know what to believe now we've got
some methods that we you know at scale
you're kind of believing that the the
result I'm just curious because it's
it's actually an incredibly important
yeah I will say it's something we want
to investigate further and I can see
that there is like I've seen a benchmark
papering about archive for detecting
spatially variable genes yeah but I'm
yeah I have to so yeah you haven't made
up your mind yet right right right yeah
ah thanks Judy again for your for your
podcasting that uh it's time for lunch
we have only an hour today uh and we
have boxes lunches outside the other
days the lunch is not provided by
sandwich but there are many places
around here and uh Ron I think that we
have a picture taking up to 30 today is
that correct
in the next break after the next session
after the American will have a whole
group picture taken okay thanks
thank you